[Música]
i
es bastante probable que al escuchar la
palabra autismo venga la imagen de un
niño varón ensimismado o bien que la
palabra pueda ser utilizada como
sinónimo de desconexión o estar al
margen de la realidad como de estar
dentro de una burbuja
y esa creencia que bastante poco dice
sobre lo que es el autismo dice y mucho
sobre la desinformación que como
sociedad aún persiste en torno a las
condiciones del espectro del autismo
y esta desinformación conforma junto con
las miedos y los prejuicios barreras
invisibles contra las que día a día
chocan las personas autistas y sus
familias
barreras invisibles pero déjenme
decirles que dejan huellas realmente muy
profundas y dolorosas porque son las
responsables de la exclusión el rechazo
y la discriminación
si no conoce a las personas autistas
podríamos realmente identificar el
esfuerzo que a diario hacen para
intentar decodificar ese lenguaje social
que nosotros intuitivamente aprendemos a
manejar algo que ellos verdaderamente en
forma espontánea no logran hacer nunca
para ello requieren intelectualizarlo a
fin de develar ese código invisible que
rigen nuestras convenciones sociales
y ese esfuerzo adicional que tratar de
develar ese código les implica implica
también un esfuerzo que para nosotros es
invisible y que se traduce en altos
niveles de tensión de frustración de
angustia y de ansiedad por solamente
nombrar algunas
así que desde hace algún tiempo
me interesa adentrarme a la posibilidad
de conocer este espectro tan diverso
desde una mirada humanista y respetuosa
y la pregunta es posible adentrarnos a
conocer el autismo desde este enfoque y
la verdad que creo firmemente que sí y
que no solamente es posible sino que es
absolutamente necesario
porque la historia del autismo hasta
hace mucho tiempo y hasta hace poco
tiempo perdón viene siendo escrita desde
afuera desde aquellos observadores que
han teorizado incluso de esas teorías
han derivado en abordajes terapéuticos
que no han intentado descifrar cuál es
la lógica detrás de esas conductas
hoy afortunadamente contamos con una
herramienta poderosísima que es el
acceso a la información digital
porque la verdad que adentrarnos en
conocer el autismo no requiere de
observadores expertos que teorizan desde
afuera requiere de aliados que
escuchemos creamos y legitimemos las
vivencias de las personas con autismo
contadas en primera persona
la verdad que esto no es tan difícil
porque hoy a tan solo un clic tenemos la
oportunidad de acceder a numerosas
historias contadas por sus propias
protagonistas donde nos abren las
puertas muchas veces de sus dolores más
profundos para que finalmente podamos
empezar a escribir en conjunto la
historia y la verdadera comprensión del
autismo
así que
como este esfuerzo yo ya lo vienen
haciendo hace mucho porque han intentado
e intentan cotidianamente develar y
aceptar esta lógica de nuestras
conductas acá se nos puede plantear una
paradoja porque a nivel social también
existe la idea bastante liviana diría de
asociar autismo con falta de empatía
podríamos preguntarnos entonces nosotros
estamos siendo realmente honestamente
empáticos con las personas con autismo
alguna vez nosotros hicimos un esfuerzo
parecido en intentar comprender cuál es
la lógica existente detrás de sus
conductas
quizás debiéramos entonces reflexionar
qué es la empatía
un concepto al cual yo adhiero y
quisiera compartir hoy con ustedes es el
del terapeuta humanista carl rogers que
dice que empatía es poder ver el mundo
desde los ojos del otro y no nuestro
mundo reflejado en sus ojos
entonces desde la perspectiva del
autismo que podríamos aprender de
nuestro mundo
la verdad que adentrarnos a conocer
nuestro mundo desde la perspectiva
autista nos brinda la oportunidad de
empezar a detenernos y reflexionar
profundamente sobre algunas de las
convenciones sociales que a veces
repetimos sin haberlos detenido siquiera
a chequear si eso sigue siendo válido
hoy
porque convengamos que la sociedad que
estamos construyendo deja bastante que
desear
y además de por los valores deja mucha
gente afuera
y eso no puede ser la sociedad lo que
uno quiere aspirar
el autismo nos ofrece una lectura de la
realidad tan simple
sin filtros de una sensibilidad
realmente muy profunda que nos muestra
cómo estamos bastante lejos muchas veces
de coincidir con los otros desde la
armonía la convivencia y el cuidado del
medio ambiente y el cuidado de los demás
desde la desde el amor y desde el
respeto mutuo utilizando dos términos
que me parecen cruciales y realmente muy
hermosos de las teorías de humberto
maturana
así que
podemos nosotros intentar empatizar con
la vivencia de una persona con autismo
la verdad es que difícilmente lo
logremos
porque sería absolutamente injusto
equiparar lo que es la vivencia a una
persona con autismo con las nuestras
porque desde esa equiparación y desde
ese esfuerzo que ellos hacen que para
nosotros así es invisible nos perdemos
de vista lo difícil que suelen ser
algunas instancias sociales para ellos
así que hoy se me ocurrió invitarlos a
tratar de evocar en su registro una
situación familiar
con la que ustedes rápidamente puedan
conectar con una situación de tensión
así que muy probablemente todos los acá
presentes
hayan intentado al menos alguna vez o ya
lo hayan logrado
y conducir un auto
yo les voy a pedir que intenten volver
en su mente y en su registro nuevamente
a esa situación ese momento de estar por
primera vez frente al volante
traten de traer a este momento la
impresión de todos esos momentos
poner
pisar el embrague poner primera
apretar el acelerador y en simultáneo y
soltando el embrague
esta secuencia perfecta que debe ser
seguida sin ningún tipo de equivocación
a fin de que logremos el objetivo de
arrancar el auto sin que se apague el
motor
es altamente probable que en ese momento
sea absolutamente imposible realizar
otra actividad al mismo tiempo
porque en ese momento requerimos de toda
la atención de nuestro cerebro
el tema es que una vez que más o menos
dominamos esa etapa
caemos en la cuenta de que para conducir
necesitamos circular
necesitamos aprender los recorridos y
encontrarnos con otros conductores
así que a ese guión de lo que yo debo
hacer al que tengo que atender
activamente se le agregan todas las
otras variables externas
estímulos impredecibles información que
muchas veces abruman
el no saber y el desconcierto ante las
acciones de los demás
y todo ese torbellino de emociones de
pensamientos que en ese momento
acompañan para intentar mantener la
calma rápidamente podemos identificar
que cualquier otra situación poco
importa en ese momento
sin embargo
si ustedes pudieron identificar la
situación de tensión
la ansiedad el miedo
algo parecido a lo que ustedes pudieron
evocar en este instante pero muchísimo
más amplificado de intenso es lo que
vive todos los días cada día de su vida
una persona con autismo
con la diferencia
que toda esta secuencia no se puede
automatizar nunca
realmente a veces la ponemos bastante
difícil
en las situaciones sociales
porque pareciera que no terminamos de
comprender
de las personas autistas tienen un
cerebro que funciona de una manera
diferente
y por lo tanto para poder afrontar
regular o filtrar toda esa información
que viene desde afuera sin ningún tipo
de filtros se percibe toda junta con el
más mínimo detalle necesita de
herramientas y de estrategias que son
específicas y propias para ellos para
poder afrontar todas las exigencias del
entorno
y volvemos a evocar la situación de
conducción
es altamente probable que hasta veamos
que puede ser hasta absolutamente
absurdo que un copiloto más o menos
sensato y coherente obligue al conductor
principiante a circular con nivel de
experticia en una arteria clave de la
ciudad en un horario pico con
condiciones climáticas adversas y puedo
además sostener una conversación
profunda coherente y fluida y encima de
todo eso mantener la calma
suena bastante absurdo el planteo
de hecho si llegase a ocurrir alguna
situación negativa o un accidente es
bastante probable que podamos
rápidamente solidarizarnos con el
conductores principiantes
sin embargo muchas de las instancias
sociales cotidianas a las que deben
hacer frente las personas autistas
se parecen bastante a este planteo
con la diferencia de que lejos de
solidarizarnos con ellos muchas veces
los hacemos sentir responsables o
culpables por sentirse abrumados
asustados agotados o estresados
realmente podemos hacer mucho
y aliviar una es bastante la vida
por qué
si hasta ahora nos detenemos a ver
cuáles son estas situaciones a las que
conducimos por ahí sin darnos cuenta de
las personas con autismo podemos
rápidamente identificar que en este
camino de la vida que compartimos no
estamos siendo muy buenos compañeros de
ruta con la comunidad autista
y eso puede cambiar y para que este
cambio sea posible no es necesario
ningún aparatología específica ni
sofisticada ni mucho menos es necesaria
ninguna inversión económica lo único que
necesitamos es una acción humana
la empatía
y si así lo hiciéramos vamos a ganar la
posibilidad
tomando prestadas unas palabras de mario
benedetti de coincidir con personas que
nos hagan ver lo que no vemos que nos
enseñen a mirar con otros ojos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a mí